this is one of the personal Rapid
Transit pods at London's Heathrow
Airport it will take you from one of the
car parks to terminal five and from
terminal five to one of the car parks
and that's about it when it was
installed in 2011 oh this was going to
be the future of Transport but hasn't
really worked out that way and more than
that they got beaten to the punch by 35
years because in 1975 a west virginia
university opened this their own
personal Rapid Transit System
the pods here in the city of Morgantown
might not be quite as sleek and rounded
but there's 70 of them they carry more
people and they go to five stations
along an eight mile track this really is
personal transit you push a button
and a car arrives to take you where you
want to go non-stop a peak times will be
a carillon every few minutes for each
separate destination PRT never shuts
down we have run 40 years without any
major incident 10 inches of snow and
we'll be fine
that's because we have a heated track
here kids don't like it because we keep
the school open there are no variables
if I'm going from point A to point B but
eight minutes it is eight minutes back
in the 1970s the only option for getting
students between all the separate
university campuses here was a fleet of
buses but Morgenthau is a city with
steep hills and narrow roads so the
result was gridlock another time
American politicians were actually
having a bit of a crazy
for systems like this Richard Nixon
announced that there was development
money available under West Virginia
Senator Robert Byrd who was famous in
part for just how much money he managed
to bring back to his own state he
managed to get Morgantown selected as
the testing site the Boeing Company and
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory
resolved with getting the system to work
the system right now can carry well over
4,000 passengers an hour every vehicle
when a departure station has a route
every time an assigned vehicle moves
over a presence detector that location
is monitored by the station electronics
which then conveys that message back to
central control room
then that message is depicted by the
mimic board in central control and each
one of those blinking lights represents
a presence detector but it also
represents five seconds and travel time
in the train world all the switching is
done on the track so the track
physically moves Tory in a vehicle down
a different pathway on a different rail
line in our system the vehicle switches
on board the result of all that 1970s
engineering was well it was massively
over-budget and little rough around the
edges to start but that happens with
prototypes the important part was it
worked and it was well enough to be
expanded and to be kept updated into the
21st century well all the problems were
having today is with obsolescence of
parts for the vehicle as well for the
electronics for the system and back in
the 70s the Minuteman missile system was
the basis for the design of the
electronics of for this system there's a
company called talas and they are here
on site now upgrading the electronics
and the software for the system the old
system uses a little bit different
technology to run the cars up and down
the guy way the cars did not know where
they were located or add-on the guideway
in the new system the tower system they
will know where they're at so that's a
big help when you're trying to ask a car
where it said the technical manual for
the system is online on WVU's website
and it is 1970s engineering genius just
like the pods that he'd run decades
later this was going to be the future of
travel so why wasn't it why aren't
systems like this everywhere well in
most cases you can do almost everything
that this can with regular light rail
with less upfront cost and less
political risk sure the PRT is a bit
faster and a bit more efficient and it's
a bit more pleasant to ride because
every journey is non-stop but the rest
of the world went with cheaper simpler
systems just with much less charge
it's a spine of our transportation
network
it is also an icon for this institution
we do have some challenges but we have
an excellent crew a dedicated passionate
crew that just finds a way to make the
system work and keep going it's that
little engine that could
thanks to everyone at the Morgantown PRT
and West Virginia University pull down
the description for more links about
them and about the college
you